c'est au néolithique après l'invention
de l'agriculture que vont apparaître les
chefs et avec les chefs les inégalités
alors comment sait-on que c'est à ce
moment là qu'apparaissent les chefs
alors on doit on le voit assez bien
alors que logiquement parce que le dans
les premiers temps du néolithique quand
vous fouillez un cimetière est bien mais
des mort emporte dans un angle au delà
tous à peu près la même chose c'est pas
tout à fait les mêmes objets pour les
hommes les femmes pour les enfants les
adultes mais envoya il n'y a pas de
différence et si on prend le cas de
l'europe à partir de moins 4500 à peu
près avant notre ère et bien on va voir
que il ya des personnages qui sont
beaucoup plus importants par exemple
dans les balkans bulgarie célèbre
cimetière de varna revers moins vingt
quatre mix de sons ou sur 3 400 tombes
certains individus ont très peu une
pointe une aiguille en os un petit vase
et d'autres ont jusqu'à 1 kg d'objets en
or ces premiers objets en or de
l'histoire humaine et en même temps sur
les côtes de l'atlantique c'est là qu'on
voit par s appelle les dolmens c'est à
dire pour les certains individus plus
important d'autres ont construit ces
énormes trous beauvau funéraire en
dalles de pierre de plusieurs leviers
dizaines de tomes dans lequel on va
trouver les objets précieux par exemple
comme à carnac des achats en pierres
vertes qui viennent d des alpes etc
donc c'est là qu'on voit effectivement
émergé
c'est ce qu'on peut appeler des chefs et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que ils
sont liées justement à des à des rituels
notamment à ses combos mégalithique ses
dolmens autour desquels on fait des
cérémonies et on sait par les textes
historiques à partir du moment où on
aura à l'écriture que les rois les
dominants se donnent toujours lié est
relié au surnaturel et les héros
européens sont sacrés au sens propre du
terme en raison du vide
ils sainte donc hors du japon des
cendres de la déesse du soleil il farah
vont faire venir les eaux du nil même de
nos jours beaucoup de beaucoup de chefs
d'état quand ils prennent leurs
fonctions vous jurer sur la bible sur le
corps ce qui prouve encore qui sont
liées au surnaturel
donc c'est le moment où ça émergent dans
le détail
enfin on peut l'observer
archéologiquement l'explication même
c'est qu'effectivement ils ont été
capables de manipuler sans doute en
toute bonne foi l'imaginaire de leurs
contemporains
[Musique]